Hello Freak bitches
time I ever met.
Alex said that weekend didn't,
um,
that's the only time you've ever heard that in Waco.
Waco first.
And then that I lost touch with him after that.
He,
he really couldn't,
he liked me again actually after I wrote the minister go.
It's like he didn't like me after I wrote my book them,
which includes all this stuff about being sneaking into Bohemian Grove cause he
thought I was too much of a debunker of Bohemian Grove.
But then when I wrote the metastatic goats,
he liked me again because he felt that I was like,
oh,
it's kind of like a bit of a,
the minister.
It goes,
it's kind of like a conspiracy book in a way.
Yeah.
So,
um,
how much different is it than the,
should we keep going with this Bohemian Grove?
Yeah,
yeah.
I get it.
There's more to say.
Uh,
so Alex and Mike decided to go in via the undergrowth.
Like I,
I saw them.
Um,
so they went in through the bushes.
They wouldn't see the bushes and there was a lot of poison oak.
I wouldn't be at all.
Scott.
Just walked in.
Yeah,
man.
Rick,
the lawyer,
this kind of preppy lawyer,
um,
artillery.
The funniest thing I've,
I've missed out of this story was it was the night before we were going to
infiltrate,
um,
Alex and Mike decided to practice being preppy.
And so they were walking down there,
worked half a day or like the code or outside their Botero rooms at talking and
a kind of a feminine way about microprocessors.
Like,
you know,
I,
I just nano technology is the future.
I think Doug Previz die.
Yeah.
Oh,
I do Johnny Reid.
I tried to kill him.
Stop.
He jumped off a building and land in a dumpster.
Right?
Oh my God.
How bad was he?
Broken.
Fucked up.
And he throw,
throw punches into the [inaudible] was a trip.
It was,
and he got a check from the government and he gave me to like bartenders around
the first.
That's what people thought,
but he lived like,
he banged his head on the dumpster and it fucking over dog.
He lived and he give his check from the government on the first of the bartender
and he torment the bartender to that check was done and they throw him.
I put it first and they will last a little about the 18th and 19th when I was a
kid,
I used to tour,
met Johnny read.
He'd gone through on the east coast,
he'd lock the bathroom from the
fuck.
You say you liked the batteries from the outside of the east coast when you
leave a bar at night,
when they close up,
right.
They locked the bathroom and then they put like a a lock bolts or if you break
in they can't.
He would go in the bathroom.
Johnny read like 11 o'clock in the morning,
the P and we locked them in there.
We leave them in there until like six o'clock at night.
We come back to have a drink.
We'd opened the bathroom and he'd come out like nothing.
I swear to God like nothing happened.
He was hilarious.
I mean one day I put my Dick on a chair next to him.
He was sending out of Boston,
my friends,
like,
which it,
see what happens and he's like,
wow.
And he just got up Johnny relived like maybe 12 years ago.
We used to give him bumps a coke and get them riled up at the,
and they just leave.
Fuck you motherfuckers.
I'll fight all of this that he just fucking leave.
Oh,
Irish Jew a Jew.
You ever have a girl you dated to kill herself?
No,
they should've
put that fucking helmet.
Grad Committee.
Your fucking Dick.
He said,
kill yourself the first time.
And when you get to your destination,
well for police it's even worse because we're perpetuating that situation.
So work,
we're the ones doing that cycle.
So when we see a 61 time I was a shift commander in the eastern district and I'm
telling my guys,
stop pulling over old white ladies.
Stop pulling over that young cute girl.
Stop.
We focus on who committed the crimes and who commit the crimes in Baltimore,
16 to 24 year old black males.
That's who's committing the crimes.
So focus on them.
That makes sense until you complete the cycle and realize that you started doing
that because of institutionalized racism in your organization.
And so when you are jacking up those guys on the corner and you do find that
dime bag,
so you sent him to jail.
Now he can't go to work the next day.
So he loses his job and then he can't make it to court.
So he gets his license suspended and then he's driving and then you are focusing
on those 16 to 24 black males.
So now you're more likely to pull them over.
Now you pull him over.
Now he has a suspended license.
Now he gets his license is revoked and now he can't get to the job legally and
you just,
and now,
now he's dealt.
It's left with selling drugs on the corner.
So you were were creating it.
We have to step back and realize what the facts are and what we're doing.
And the number one problem is the drug war.
And then we have money in politics.
These are our two big issues that we have to solve before we get anywhere.
Well,
what does the money in politics,
how's that player?
So I don't think we can change anything until we stopped having politicians that
are serving their donors versus serving the people.
So somebody that's talking like me is never going to run a police agency as long
as all their corporate donors are saying,
no,
no.
You keep those animals and the cages because that's what they do.
I mean,
that's a good joke in Baltimore that police are actually the zookeepers.
She keeps everything in it.
Don't let it hit the county.
So,
so that's,
that's our role.
That's what we're doing.
So your mayors and your politicians are going to continue to encourage that.
They're not going to take a risk and say,
all right,
how do we lower juvenile possession of marijuana?
You know that I know you do.
You know,
you legalize it.
Yeah.
And you control it.
And rates actually go down.
Whether we're overseas or were in Colorado,
your possession rates for marijuana will go down among juveniles.
But we don't do that.
We keep looking at everything like we're a hammer searching for now and we keep
looking for what we're going to hit to stop it.
Instead of standing back and using science and figuring out what are we actually
going to do to fix this problem,
what we'll actually have results.
There are,
there are behaviors.
This book,
the murderer is so fucking incredible.
This guy,
Richard Walter.
There are behaviors that people like certain guys will rape and kill a woman,
but when they're raping her,
if she dies in the process,
they'll stop immediately because they don't want the cops that think they're
freaks.
All kinds of weird shit.
Like,
well,
that was the thing about this green river guys and he didn't want them to know
that he fucked them after they were.
That's right.
He didn't want to admit it because he had an ego and ego and the guy he,
the way he got them to do it,
he was looking at it.
You wouldn't be the first guy.
A lot of guys who've done that's right.
Yeah.
He's like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah.
He goes,
Hey,
I actually,
I did do that.
I didn't do that.
I do like they used to,
they got a guy,
I'm a high level of terrorists who,
um,
had never seen porn and they started showing him porn.
Oh.
And I said,
and he,
it was like the carrot and the stick and he was like,
Hey,
do you want to see more of this?
Will show you more at the tellers scene.
And he started talking just to see it.
No,
he was a,
he became up in a very strict Islamic society.
So they showed them some dick slot as life shit.
What do you want to know?
These really hot girls so much.
Excited to tell you something,
man.
Bella,
Donna and Carol.
We'll get you talking if you have a,
and we'll get you throwing up,
but she puts up baseball bat up around us and they say,
hey,
go to Fossa.
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll freaking tell you whatever you want on the podcast.
She was fucking great.
I'll say Kira.
Yeah,
she was cool.
Smart.
The school shooting and he went like this.
No,
no,
I wouldn't go with fucking great greats in 10th grade.
Might be a little intense and too much of a big word to you.
Be a little hyperbole there.
May never seen one of our parents.
How about that?
Fuck,
haven't I swear to God.
I have never seen her.
Not One.
You'd never seen her work?
Not a lot.
Did you not do research for that episode?
Yeah.
Well I know she's,
I went Jensen.
Yeah,
she does some heavy shit too.
Oh,
almost too much.
Where you go.
Okay,
well that can't be well on my podcast,
she said her skin was bad because she was taken in her darn and said,
I think you're taking in too much testosterone.
Too many loads.
Yeah.
She's got 20 a you got a whore on your hands.
Testing.
You imagine if you take it,
somebody loads it.
It changes your biological profile.
Imagine if you're just dating.
A girl said,
come my fucking face keeps breaking out.
What's happening?
These fucking guys bust all over my face,
man.
I will push us in her.
Oh,
you're in just so much come in her body probably annually.
A lot of it and go right orally.
I don't that doesn't make that noise when I'm coming,
unless I'm fine.
Yeah.
I've never had that noise because there's some hot about that though.
I would agree with you.
I agree.
I like a turbo slot and I have always will to contact us and have her print up
that shirt
with glitter.
I'll bake.
You assured us
Hashtag [inaudible] why don't we make them all work?
No,
it's not.
Take Turbo slept.
I guarantee you if you put out a turbo sled shirt fell out.
It was to ask you for the girls limited edition for women.
You don't have the balls.
I say dude,
you can fucking limited edition.
Just make 20 they'll sell instantly.
Zach,
when he tweets we get now about terrible,
terrible,
so it's a great,
great word.
It's funny Theresa slash.
Slug or is it just turbo?
Turbo slut.
It's a great designation.
Is it one word or two words?
Two words I guess two weeks.
Terrible schools to Hashtag turbo slash hashtag turbo slot.
Oh,
turbo sled.
That's going to like anything that happens in the news now from now on,
Hashtag turbos anytime a girl does something fucked up,
it's going to be Hashtag [inaudible] turbo sled grilled cheese on a man
can work for guys too and make that t shirt.